can we like gossip real quick oh you're
gonna bring up this one Mark has been
excited to talk about that yes
this might be the most important thing
that's ever happened okay okay
let's gossip real quick this is beyond
gossip this cuts to the core of what it
means to be a man this transcends
everything this is the Odyssey okay
we're about to watch The Odyssey siren
dude
siren huh all right if anyone doesn't
know okay bust it open Ariana Grande was
married to a guy obviously famous pop
star she is co-starring on Wicked okay
her co-star in Wicked is this guy Ethan
Slater okay he formerly was SpongeBob on
Broadway okay so he's popping in the
Broadway scene that's why you love him
and the pro I saw him hate on that I'm
saying what he did work real hard to get
to he's one of the greatest he's one of
the greatest actors in the world and
Ariana was married to a realtor yeah
exactly what's wrong with that no you
said it why are you hating
bro
[Laughter]
one of the biggest popsicles in the
world she's co-starring with this guy
right and then basically the two of them
cheat on their respective respective uh
fathers and wives and Men allegedly I
mean yeah I don't know them I just found
out about this story from you talking
about a legend yeah yeah he dressed like
Patrick Star I mean he's a voucher for
this guy I believe I believe he's on
SpongeBob's team I believe all women
now they're both divorcing their people
they're dating this guy eat this later
just recently had a baby with his wife
that's where it's [__] and his wife a
year and a half ago what do you does the
baby
that's one of the greatest roles in
Broadway Bros one of the biggest
cartoons ever I love SpongeBob I've
watched all the seasons you didn't even
watch it I didn't watch it I will be
honest but I'm at least giving some
respect to a man that played at the
bottom of the ocean or wherever it is
Square Pants yeah
that also has a personality and you
should it's a huge show it's one of the
biggest shows on Broadway kids love it I
would have gone to see it if I was a
little younger
all I'm saying is you don't have to
throw salt like now he's in a real you
know musical he's uh it's a movie yeah
it's a movie a musical movie yeah
yeah so it's awesome yeah but now he
left his uh high school sweetheart who
just had a baby with uh for Ariana
Grande
some say that Ariana Grande
uh has made a habit of this yeah
she has a song break up with your
boyfriend because I'm bored
that's a song
[Music]
as a banger he just sang the [__] out
there
I'm gonna sing that the next song
yeah but I'll still searches
concert last night bro how do you not
know wow so she has a history of this
yeah I love
god well this is the guy I wish I could
be on The View
are we gossiping yeah this is the guy
she left her spouse for
oh wow stay up Kings I'm saying
anything's possible Anything is Possible
why are you acting like it's normal for
a person that does theater
[Music]
what does he get to do it because he's
he's a musical theater guys
whole life right you didn't even play
sports go back to Mark being
homeschooled and dressing up with
suspenders and a [__] he's not even
going to soccer
why does he get to take that arm and he
got a brock dude damn what'd you he's a
little brother oh bro so yeah here's the
thing you're a hater but Ariana
but here's the thing can you blame
Ariana she's been famous since she's a
child anything she wants she just asks
for and then gets yeah so I don't even
know if she thinks that she's doing
anything wrong like I want that man
I don't care what anybody needs to do to
get it for me but that's what I want so
I
hey I want a reservation at a restaurant
well it's uh it's all reserved okay well
do what you have to do yeah but she's
also married though
you know that this level of like
narcissism that it takes to be where
they are it doesn't matter right like
it's just whatever I need that's a good
point you're fun you're fun for as long
as you feed my narcissism yeah and then
once you stop feeding it well we need
somebody else to feed it yeah and
nothing feeds narcissism like a man
that's taken oh yeah I'm so great that
that taken man with a newborn baby will
leave his wife and child for this [__]
yeah yeah
that's a wicked [__] right now that is
the Wicked Witch of the West right there
when you think about it that's Meta Meta
yeah no that's meta I think no no uh uh
what is that acting where you do it all
the time method method method yeah
you're with the ex-wife said what she
said this is like the thing that sort of
my wife
she said uh she's not a girls girl she
said Ariana Grande is not a girl's girl
my family's just collateral and that's
sort of like what pushed yeah this big
on Twitter right now so Ariana Grande is
perfect I hate that don't go at Ariana
like hold your man accountable nah but
here's here's where I will this kid for
this kid and this is kind of tomorrow's
Point what do you mean this kid he's
young he's a nice guy you know but this
is to Mark's point this is a kid that
grew up in musical theater he's doing
Broadway plays this is not somebody
girls are going crazy over suddenly one
of the biggest pop stars on Earth is
into you it's just like this is wild
this is not something I ever saw coming
I could see you being moved by that what
don't agree with me now
he's also he's just coming from such a
jealous Place yeah yeah you were coming
back
SpongeBob for no reason nobody asked
what his [__] discomfort we couldn't
hear what he's famous for bro that's
what his biggest role was because
this is your Jake Paul just hating on
this man for no reason bro he looks like
Jews Clues
I'm gonna sing off with this guy I'm
gonna do a sing all about you oh my God
he looked like a singer we're doing this
thing off and then you're doing the
spawn with Jake oh yeah
celebrity [__] son you can't be just
throwing her A-list celebrities they all
throw it bro no they all throw it do
they that's all they do
hey little celebrities they just need to
get filled up that's what they want you
just got to be like yo back off [__]
no no not in your SpongeBob
when your response does it absorbs yeah
I'm ready bro
you gotta chill see the show I don't
know what that even means I don't know
you're the only one laughing
is this what it's like being you when we
talk about movies yeah we're like
backdrafted like yeah [__] exactly all
I'm trying to say is yes I get it he's
like I'm never gonna get this
opportunity again I gotta Jump On It
She's Dangerous that is a wild thing
she's dangerous bro but you listen as a
dude you got to be you know on your p's
and q's you don't think you could get
something better than that
no
what about Margot Robbie when she's
single you don't think Ethan Slater
could slide in MCM clicking his heels
together in this picture it's
unbelievable you don't think women are
inside this guy
but again another Ariana Grande whatever
he wants
yeah
thank you seize the day he does have Six
Flags mascot energies
like yo Smash and you go yeah he's
straight on Broadway though right what
does that mean I Scott straight guy lead
oh that's another thing
he been through [__] like he's been on
Broadway
straight dude in ballet or Broadway
smashes absolutely everything
yeah
this is high school sweetheart he was
with he cheated on nobody he waited
yo Black Swan
Natalie Portman exactly you got Natalie
Portman yeah ballet the creative
director that did uh Black Swan yeah but
he's not on Broadway
but he's in the ballet world yeah but
he's not on Broadway no but he they got
to listen
if you're a straight guy in the dance
world or the Broadway World the level of
confidence you have from every single
woman that you're interacting with that
you're spending literally 18 hours a day
throwing [__] think about it it's not
only are you the only straight person
that they're interacting with they're
the most insecure people on the planet
we're talking about actors and
ballerinas who are told constantly
they're not good enough and then there's
one straight dick that they all have to
share and when it's never alone
the premier ballerina ballerina or
whatever is always what to do so the
other underlinked ballerina is like oh
if I could only have that one straight
dick so their egos are here you've never
even seen an eagle like that so he
probably walked on set with our whatever
her name is
and he's just like fine I'm gonna throw
her some [__] sauce yeah
bro once you guys realize that the
patriarchy is responsible for everything
bad in the world then you'll finally be
at a point where you could tuck your
[__] between your legs and jerk off
backwards in the mirror
you know what I mean you could do it I'm
surprised you stuck
he was running out of breath that was
good I got it all out I got it all out I
might not be [__] SpongeBob
out
now easy you are a hater bro yo [__] you
you're cool you're a hater bro how you
brought those pictures up I just Googled
his name bro you could have found
something which one you want which one
you want also big feet
win they kind of look like Ariana Grande
I I don't even know if I don't even know
if that's not Ariana Grande
did she change her hair yet or she's
still just doing a ponytail
I don't know she has never not been in a
ponytail
let's go baby
yo you
kill Mark isn't I'm I'm on his side I'm
bailing him out are you an animal Mom
I'm bailing him out you're right he's a
theater kid his whole life all of a
sudden he gets given the crit like a
Faustian bargain trade your whole life
for the greatest pop star ever and you
go yeah it's a tough decision and all
the guys that are saying oh I would
never do this no no you could never oh
Ariana Grande
but I'm with you that's my point good
point that's a good point I'm on his
side you guys are hating on him he's not
here blaming men for everything yeah
I don't care dude it's men's fault you
got soft look at you man spreading all
over the couch yeah and spreading over
the couch you know what I mean like
you know you're doing whatever you can
I'm just saying like it's disgusting
what men are doing out there taking
advantage of a poor girl like that she's
a married woman alone in London what do
you think she's gonna do dude what do
you think she's gonna do do a what a
[__] jerk that guy is an alpha look
at how alpha he is your way out of this
don't jump your way I have a picture
right there don't go out of your real
opinions zoom in on that picture what
happened a guy that had a problem with
women swimming look at that alpha male
right there dude look at that
look at him barely being able to hold a
spatula dude think about how I'll change
in two weeks ago you changed about that
like look at this look at go in closer
go in [__] closer no you changing
look at that look at the shock and awe
hell yeah
anyway the point is you're a [__]
you're one of the worst human beings in
history what did I do what do you mean
what did you do what do you mean I'm
saying I'm on your side you did that
thing where you listed his credits as if
you weren't making fun of him even
though you were and that's the meanest
thing you can do because you're not
making fun of him you're just saying
them and then you make us do the work of
making fun because you don't respect
Broadway so any Broadway show I could
say you'd be like
best facts watch ready oh my God pull up
his Wikipedia picture oh stop it
I said how did good get up in a picture
hey hey EDP out here bro bro looking
like an EDP what the [__] bro I'm saying
he did he he won I'm on his side he won
I am as well dude we're on the same page
you're just jealous of him very clearly
that's the only thing I'm noticing yes
he's more on her than him
I take back everything exactly thank you
man I looked at that one right there do
your [__] thing boy that's nuts
do your thing boy he's up do your thing
she makes that hairstyle popular then
he's risk God City boys are up that's
what I'm saying he went from Broadway to
[__] Ariana Grande
MSG [__] you Alex
you gotta do that
[__] hat dumb [__] hat
[__] idiot hat look at his dumb
[__] hat
stupid idiot